make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so with absolute carnage being out
and the fact that the story focuses on
carnage going after everybody who's ever
had a symbiote we did the first part of
the first issue right the first issue
split into three stories right it's part
one two and three cuz we're gonna cover
those those three and individual parts
and then you know kind of go forward
from there it's released monthly so it
should give us plenty of time but in the
in the in the meantime what I want to do
here is I want to run over everybody
who's ever had a simulator at least how
all the symbiotes function inside of
Marvel Comics that way you guys have an
idea what to expect right because at
this point there's no reason not to
believe that Donnie Cates wouldn't just
bring back all these symbionts in some
form or fashion or the very least go
after all those individuals who were
still living who have still had a
symbiote so you guys may end up seeing
some characters that you haven't really
seen before now to kind of begin with
the obvious we're gonna start with venom
who's probably the most famous symbiote
in all of Marvel Comics and since the
introduction of the venom Simeon it's
actually had several hosts and so what
we're gonna do first is we're gonna go
over the major hosts and then touch
briefly on those who have hosted the
symbiote for only a short amount of time
now the first host that we saw bonded to
the Venom symbiote was actually Peter
Parker during the events of Secret Wars
Peter was actually some into battleworld
along with a group of marvel's most
popular heroes by the Beyonder to do
battle with a group of supervillains now
while on battle world spider-man's
costume is damaged and he creates a new
black and white costume is able to
produce webbing of its own now back on
earth spider-man would take the costume
to Reed Richards who would examine it in
determine there was actually a sentient
alien life form and that it was simply
attending to bond to Peter now later on
Peter would reject the symbiote as it
would take control of his body while he
was sleeping and fight crime
therefore not allowing Peter's body to
rest and so ultimately Peter explored
sisimiut sweetnesses to sound and uses
the bells in a church to drive the venom
simian away now later a depressed and
disgraced reporter named Eddie Brock
would wonder the same Church Eddie's
career of course had been ruined due to
him botching the biggest story of his
life by revealing the wrong person to be
a notorious serial killer and so after
spider-man later captured the real
killer
Eddie Brock began to develop a hatred
for him and he blamed him for ruining
his career now sensing this hatred the
Venom symbiote sought out Eddie and
bonded to him and so Eddie would go on
to be the longest tenured and most well
known host of the Venom symbiote and
would fight both against and alongside
spider-man at various times and so
eventually Eddie in the symbian manually
part ways and Eddie sells the symbiote
to the highest bidder at a super villain
auction now the next time that we saw
the Venom symbiote ended a bond
itself - Mac Gargan previously known as
a spider-man rogue scorpion now Gargan
joins Norman Osborn's sinister 12 and
later the Thunderbolts and then
eventually the Dark Avengers and Gargan
is separated from the venomous idiot
following the siege on Asgard in which
the Dark Avengers were defeated and
Gargan was incarcerated now after Peters
high school classmate Flash Thompson
enlists in the army and then loses both
of his legs in the Iraq war he's
approached by the US government to be a
special agent and so while on
assignments Flash's bonded with the
Venom symbiote for periods of time that
are shorter than 48 hours to prevent
permanent bonding and after his tenure
as a government agent comes to an end
flash joins the Avengers and later the
guardians of the galaxy where he
eventually returns to the simians home
planet of Clint heart where the simian
has purged of his impurities that caused
it to do evil in the past and so flash
eventually becomes a space knight and an
agent of the cosmos and dedicates
himself to keeping the peace throughout
the galaxy now eventually flash is
separated from the symbiote during a
fight with an FBI agent wearing a
high-tech suit that he uses to send the
simian into a state of enraged confusion
and forcing it to flee the battle and so
the symbiote eventually find its way to
leap rise a former Army Ranger turned
criminal during an illegal arms deal and
so when the symbiote finds price has
actually been significantly weakened and
begs Christ to use a symbiote for heroic
purposes as flash had done however price
ends up refusing this and uses the
symbiote to further his life of crime
before being defeated by spider-man and
Eddie Brock and separated from the
symbiote itself now in addition to these
primary house there have been several
other temporary House of the Venom
symbiote which will go through a little
more quickly the Kree Warrior tell car
is bonded to the symbiote shortly after
its birth and uses it to infiltrate the
scroll forces during the kree-skrull war
before being captured and separated from
the Sumida itself at one time the
symbian attempted to bond to Ben Riley a
clone of Peter Parker but failed to do
so Eddie Brock's ex-wife and becomes she
venom when the sim be had bonds with her
to save her life after being shot by the
Sin Eater
the serial killer at the center of the
story that ruined Eddie Brock's career
mafia member Don Fortunato purchases the
symbiote at the supervillain auction I
mentioned earlier and it bonds to his
son Angelo Angelo ends up running from a
battle with spider-man and the symbiote
abandons him due to his cowardice
during a jump between buildings causing
him to fall to his death Carol Danvers
briefly hosts the symbiote after it's
temporarily separated from Matt Guardian
during the see John has guard during
flash Thompson's tenure as venom
Thunderbolt Ross comes his apartment as
the Red Hulk and the symbiote perceives
him to be a threat and bonds to him too
prevent him from harming flash now
incidentally at the conclusion of
immortal Hulk number 20 it's revealed
that Thunderbolt Ross is missing and
that this has something to do with the
brief exposure to the simian now during
the time as a superior spider-man Doctor
Octopus actually engaged Flash Thompson
as agent venom in a battle believing him
to be a supervillain now we're Auto
attacked venom with fire which is one of
the weaknesses of the simian he
separated from Flash and ultimately
captured it when the simian wrote free
it bonded to Otto who was inhabiting the
body of Peter Parker who then uses
Scindia to fight crime and superior
venom before returning the symbiote to
flash after realizing the effects it had
on his psyche while venom was with the
guardians of the galaxy the symbiote
bonded itself to Groot rocket raccoon
and Dratch before the guardians arrived
on the planet Clint Hart and the semi it
was once again bonded to flash the
simian also briefly merges with mercury
or the 4d man whose evil nature
counteracts the purification the Symbian
had previously undergone on his home
planet and more recently a small piece
of the Symbian actually bonded with
Mysterio during the symbiote spider-man
series to allow him to defeat kingpin
now aside from venom the most prominent
symbian in the Marvel Universe and the
one to the center of the ongoing story
absolute carnage is of course carnage
himself now the current symbiote was
created when the venom Samia Brooke
Eddie Brock out of prison effectively
making carnage the son of venom the
crown of symbiotes first host was Brock
sell me and vicious serial killer Cletus
Kasady the symbionts enhanced powers
combined with Cletus the psychopathic
nature turned carnage into a nearly
unstoppable killing machine that would
plague both spider-man and venom for
years now carnage briefly left Cassidy
to bond itself with John Jameson the son
of Jay jonah Jameson who carnage used to
commit more murders before leaving him
to bond with spider-man which was at the
time not Peter Parker but his clone Ben
Riley but Riley was able to resist the
symbiotes murderous urges and tried to
destroy the symbiote by blasting it with
microwaves now although the symbiote was
separated from Riley it escaped and REE
bonded with Cassidy during the events of
superior spider-man villains wizard and
Klaw tried to bomb the simia to
lobotomize Cletus Kasady to use it a
team of supervillains that were forming
but ultimately failed instead carnage
bonadu-- scientist Karl Malus whose
dubbed the superior carnage and it's
controlled by wizard and clock until he
turns on them and then ultimately ends
up killing clock now malice was
eventually separated from carnage by an
explosion and the symbiote briefly bond
with wizard and at one point while the
carnage symbiote was presumed dead a
sample of it being study by dr. Karla
Unger bonded with her and destroyed her
in the process once again seeking out
and eventually rebonding with Kaz
now when the final issues of dance lots
amazing spider-man run Norman Osborn
steals the carnage symbiote from a
shield storage facility and then bonds
with it
Norman then ingest the Goblin serum
which neutralizes the traditional
weakness of sound and fire and so Norman
ends up transferring part of the
symbiote to his grandson Normie but the
Simeon appears to be destroyed by
spider-man and Harry Osborn removes most
of the symbiote from Norman although
some of it does remain not again to the
more nuanced parts carnage actually
bonded to the Silver Surfer to become
carnage cosmic but was quickly returned
to Cassidy before being sealed in a
prison erroneously believed to be
inescapable carnage also bonds with dr.
Tanis knees after Cletus Kasady is
presumed to be dead after being ripped
in half by the century Neves briefly
becomes the new carnage before Cletus is
found to be alive and reclaims a sim yet
for himself however the carnage symbiote
reproduces and the offspring bonds with
knees to create the superhero scorn who
would later be corrupted by Knowle the
god of the simius and we start a cult
devoted to him before being killed by
Cletus Kasady
who is the possession of another
symbiote called Grendel which we'll get
into a little bit later now for the
other symbiotes apart from venom and
carnage there are a litany of symbiotes
populating the Marvel Universe and venom
lethal protector The Life Foundation
tries to create a utopian society for
its wealthy clients in the midst of the
feared nuclear fallout from the Cold War
and they do this by timming to create a
police force to keep order by kidnapping
Eddie Brock and extracting five
offspring from the venom symbian each of
the five offspring bond with Life
Foundation security guards Lasher with
Raymond Hernandez phage with Carl mock
agony with Leslie guessin area riot with
Trevor Cole and scream with Donna Diego
the five fought venom and spider-man and
were thought to be destroyed by an age
accelerating device but survived due to
intervention by the Life Foundation and
so scream would eventually kill her
siblings and although the host would
perish the simius themselves would
survive and be taken to the vault super
prison and would be fused into a new
symbian that would simply call itself
hybrid now hybrid would actually bond
with the vault prison guard scott
washington and would function as an
antihero
until being murdered by eddie brock in
his quest to kill all the symbionts now
once again the simians would survive and
during the carnage USA mini-series
Lasher phage riot and agony would bond
briefly with deadpool and finally into a
German Shepherd and which technically
become the new hybrid before Noah was
awakened and the Soviets separated and
took over a family of four moving into
Daniel ways venom solo series venom was
cloned by the iraq corporation which
sought to end all life on
the clone was actually derived from a
piece of the original Venom's tongue and
originally refused to bond with any of
the prospective hosts offered to it
before briefly bonding with Alphonse
Ponyo an elderly mental patient before
killing him the clone symbian later
bonded to US Army lieutenant Patricia
Robinson after killing a succession of
brief hosts and attending to bond with
Wolverine
now Robertson adopted the name she venom
and would set out to find and kill the
original venom but the cloned symbiote
would actually abandon Robertson and
merge with Eddie Brock instead and so
later this portion of the symbiote would
bond with Andy Benton a student of flash
Thompson's when he attempted to give her
part of his venom Samiha to save her
life after she was poisoned by Jack
O'Lantern and Andy embrace the semi its
power and adopted the name mania and
initially used it to fight crime but was
later corrupted by a demonic force
called the hell mark and she began
murdering criminals now flash eventually
absorbed the mania symbiote until the
helm art could be suppressed and then
returned it to Andy and Andy was most
recently seen being attacked by Cletus
Kasady in the lead up to absolute
carnage where she survived and then went
to warn Eddie of Cassidy's plan to
collect the genetic code of symbiote
hosts to free null from his prison now
Andy was eventually separated from mania
by Lee Price who used a flamethrower to
exploit the simians weakness to fire and
price took the simia for himself and
then adopted the name maniac now price
was eventually imprisoned for his crimes
and was visited in prison by Cletus
Kasady
masquerading as Eddie Brock who in turn
killed price and took the mania symbian
for himself now another offspring of the
Venom symbiote was actually created when
the symbiote once again tried to bond
with Eddie Brock now Brock who had
recently been cured of cancer was
attacked by Venom's host Mac Gargan then
when the simia touched Eddie Brock the
antibodies that were produced by Brock's
white blood cells charged with the life
force energy used to cure his cancer and
a new sim yet known as anti-venom was
formed the anti-venom Samia does not
have the weaknesses of fire and heap
that most symbiotes possess it can also
produce antibodies to treat a variety of
illnesses and so Eddie would actually
carry the anti-venom symbiote until it
sacrifice itself to heal a group of
infected with the spider virus during
the Spider Island storyline and so the
anti-venom symbiote was seen once again
when it was used to create a serum to
treat the toxic shock syndrome plaguing
the Venom symbiote and Flash Thompson
was given the serum and became
anti-venom during the venom Inc
storyline now when Karnas learned that
he was going to produce an offspring of
his own he resolved to kill the spawn as
soon as it was born
but was too weak to do so instead he
bonded the symbiote called toxin to a
New York City police officer named
Patrick Mulligan and
hide the simian from venom who was
seeking it out as a potential partner
now is the toxin symbiote grew stronger
venom and carnage realized that they
needed to join forces in order to
destroy it but toxin was saved by
spider-man's intervention and after some
time with a simian Mulligan is murdered
by Blackheart who bonds fragments of The
Scindia two clones of x-23 and so
eventually the crime master captures
Eddie Brock and bonds him to the toxin
symbiote who keeps it until he
sacrifices toxin to stop carnage from
resurrecting the Dark Eldar God C'thun
following this carnage quest to revive
C'thun also resulted in the creation of
another offspring named rays who bonded
to FBI agent Clair Dixon and a sailor
named Jubilee LaVon scatter before being
destroyed during the banishment of
c'thun and so most recently Donnie cases
introduce a lot of new lore to the
symbiote race and a lead-up to absolute
carnage Grendel is a dragon-like symbian
and one of the earliest created by null
to consume entire civilizations
throughout the galaxy Grindle's first
run-in with earth during the Viking Age
where it was defeated by Thor and
entombed in a glacier however pieces of
Rendell made their way to earth and
bonded with various hosts to lay the
foundation of the cult of null now
Grendel would later be found and
unfollowed by shield and fragments that
will be used to try and create a new
super soldier program during the Vietnam
War one of the five fragments was
codenamed Tyrannosaurus and would bond
with wounded soldier Rex Strickland Rex
and the rest of the soldiers bonded with
the pieces of Grendel were overcome with
bloodlust and Wolverine in what seemed
to be Nick Fury but was in reality a
life model decoy were sent to stop the
group of sim soldiers now eventually the
train of stories Simbi had separated
from Rex and briefly bonded with Logan
before being separated from him by Rex
and so when Fury's life model decoy
self-destructive to kill any witnesses
the symbiote once again bonded with
wretch to save him having been moved by
his compassion however ultimately
Rex didn't survive and instead the piece
of the Grendel symbiote began adopting
his appearance and identity missile the
Tyrannosaurus symbiote would later fight
alongside venom against null and
sacrifice itself in attempt to destroy
Noll unsuccessfully and so brindle was
subsequently collected by the maker the
ultimate universe version of Reed
Richards before being stolen from him by
the cult of null and as far as we know
Grindle is currently bonded to host
Cletus Kasady who also used it to
resurrect Emil Craig the man
misidentified as a Sin Eater by Eddie
Brock who's been sent to destroy Eddie
so yeah there's a ton of symbionts in
the Marvel Universe and it's very
complicated and it's a huge mess it's a
bit of a nightmare to be honest with you
guys a lot of that really took place in
the 1990s in the early 2000s it's been
Bunker's that's where the reasons why I
love Donnie Cates run because he's sort
of clearing it all up but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys with
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]